a doctor came and she starts like
rubbing my forehead and i remember that
very well that was very comforting she
rubs my forehead she's like we're gonna
have to take your leg i'm like no
it was fort macon here in north carolina
um super super nice beach oh yeah
everybody goes there and i i've gone
there since i was a kid like little
little so like it was just another one
of them beach days to me i was like
nothing crazy we were all having a
really good time and my dad's
girlfriend's little son who had just
turned seven
uh we were all you know trying to play
with him mess with him kayla goes let's
play mermaids i'm like yes like
leaned backwards to kind of flop
backwards onto my back and then swim
backwards and come back up like a
mermaid
um but once i had gone backwards i had
stepped on something and then
the chaos began i felt
i thought it was my dad's back i thought
it was my dad swimming underwater to
joke around with me again so i started
laughing and i look over and i see all
right kale's above the water my dad's
above the water
anayas is above the water oh everybody's
above the water what is this the way i
remember i feel a sh i felt a
sharp pain on my ankle
and then nothing else it felt like
forever i i was i felt like i was under
there for 20 minutes but it was more 20
seconds
it wasn't long at all when i was under
the water i knew that my dad was going
to come get me so i was just like
wondering when i was like all right my
dad's going to come get me give it a
second he's going to be here i just
remember him
pulling me back and i was like dad
please help me please help me he just
kept going i got you i got you i got you
so we get most of the way back to shore
he's carrying me but you know he just
punched a shark like five times so i
didn't see the shark and i don't think
anybody saw the shark they might have
just saw the fins
um
but
um after my dad was like carrying me
back he says he saw two fins so there
were two sharks um still had the whole
leg attached to me it was like really
really awful like they could like you
could see bone you could see teeth mark
in the bone and there was a man named
roger
and he
was it was his wedding anniversary she
got him a really nice belt for his
wedding
their anniversary
and
thank god because you know somebody ran
up to him said can i please have this
belt and very calmly roger just took it
off gave it to him and they sent him
another belt for free they sent him
another belt
i was on a helicopter originally they
took me to one
hospital but they didn't have a trauma
bay
and the closest place that had a trauma
bay was an hour away
so they
uh wait for the helicopter to land in
the parking lot i was i was just glad
that there was air conditioning in the
back of the
of the ambulance someone was nice
i was distressed like in my heart
like i was i was freaking out a little
bit um
but i didn't feel much pain honestly
um i had never had like a broken bone or
anything before this so like all of this
i was just kind of sitting there and i
felt the way that tv static looked you
know like when your foot falls asleep
that's how i felt i don't think i was
bleeding much then
but like they were still very clearly
concerned about me so when they get me
into the actual room
um they i was sitting there i'm like how
are they gonna get off my bikini like
that's gonna be weird a doctor came and
she starts like rubbing my forehead and
i remember that very well that was very
comforting she rubbed my forehead she's
like we're gonna have to take your leg
i'm like no
she's like yeah we have to i'm sorry
and so i wanted to cry but my body
wouldn't let me cry i was really scared
that i was in the icu
um even though i didn't have to be in
the icu they told me that i was really
scared of
the like idea of like dying during
surgery i was really scared of that but
every time i had a surgery i swear i
like shut my eyes and open them and i
was good again i was like whoa crazy the
first surgery i had was when i first
came in obviously
and they they amputated my leg and um
took two of my fingers and then they
like just left my hand
kind of like wrapped until they could
figure out
what to do they gave me like a nerve
graft and stuff so
the thumb is the only finger that was
bit twice so it got
hit twice across the ligaments this is
the this other thumb is the only one
that wasn't fit at all
um
this finger is an anomaly they say
because
none of the regular circulation works in
it um it's kind of just kept alive by
blood capillaries
um this finger is also good but
in between all of my joints
um there's like scar tissue
and it stops my fingers from being able
to pull down and i also got a nerve
graft
um and this big old flap right here
which is a piece of my back
i'd probably go through about six leg
amputations before i had to go through
the lip the hand thing again the the
hand
like
you think about it your foot kind of
just does one thing and that's just kind
of like
walk or whatever
and i figured that out fast anyway i'm
not even wearing my leg right now i
don't even need it right now
um but with hands like you gotta like
like it does a lot of stuff you know it
took me
a long time to figure out how to button
my jeans and how to
brush my teeth and it took me like a
good year to figure out how to put my
hair up again two weeks into my hospital
stay um
this man comes in
and he's like hey paige i'm i'm shane
and i also have an amputated leg and
they told me i'd never have a prosthetic
because it's so far up but i figured it
out and he made his own i'm like that's
really awesome man
he explained to me he's like now this is
kind of like learning how to drive stick
before you learn how to drive automatic
so
like you know how to do everything and
every single one i'm like okay
and it was really really really hard
it was like and i figured it out within
like
a couple days but it was still really
hard like it took a lot of
me just kind of standing there for a
second figuring out how i'm gonna take
my next steps um
but it had like no resistance to
anything so
like once you once you like kicked it
out it was out and then it came
immediately right back in
and with my new leg
um
it does have resistance and it'll it'll
wait a minute before going back down and
kicking out and stuff like that so it's
like it's a really like my new leg is
very very nice i really like it
so
we actually flew out to florida to go
talk to shark researchers like
professionals
they think based on the teeth marks in
the bone and the environment that was
going on
um they think it was a bull shark
you know they're just creatures man
we're all just creatures just doing our
best
i don't see
you know like they're not evil to me
they're just animals doing animal stuff
my cat bites me all the time and i still
love them i used to make really stupid
jokes and like i never meant it
obviously but like if like something
like really inconvenient happened like
uh like i forgot a pencil to class i'm
like wow i'm gonna kill myself for real
i would say that all the time i don't
say that anymore so i was 17 when i got
bit and i just turned 20.
i just turned 17 also so it's kind of
like we're almost to the three year mark
so my shark aversary is the 2nd of june
and me and my dad and
my sister and kale and my boyfriend will
all go out and have some delicious
dinner together and you know we'll just
hang out it's a good day
so i'm gearing up to graduate
cosmetology school super excited
i think after that at some point i want
to go back to school like a four-year
place or something for biology because i
really liked biology in high school
um and
just kind of hanging out with my cats i
really love them and i have a job and i
got my license thank god finally i like
being alive i think it's cool and you
know having all the people that i do
around me and the stuff that i do have
it makes it hard to not be happy and so
i'm just really appreciative for them
just to be around
my parents would tie us together via a
rope so that we were always together and
i could always make sure she obeyed the
therapist when she heard that story was
just
like really shocked and she looked at me
and she said elizabeth that's child
abuse